I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight thanks for
joining us
Biden's Fantasy Island
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
Joe Biden knows he's in trouble not only
are Americans turning against his
presidency they're turning against him
personally
Biden's political staff they know this
they're not dumb totally dumb at least
thus their only other option is to
create
like an alternative reality one where
Biden goes from a globalist wrecking
ball that he is to a middle class
protector it's a blue-collar blue change
we're seeing you know an economy where
we're buildings
we've built more in the last two years
since I've taken office and you can
imagine economy has grown on a solid
clip
folks I hate to disappoint them but the
Biden economic plan is working it's
working
we're calling it The unofficial launch
of his 2024 re-election bid but it was
just more of the same it was lame acting
that he brought to the State of the
Union the same thing
he's just an average Joe and he really
cares
so many of you felt like you've just
simply been forgotten
made the academic upheaval of the past
four decades
too many people have been left behind
and treated like they're invisible
maybe that's you watching from home you
wonder whether the path even exists
anymore for your children to get ahead
without having to move away I get that
well he gets it all right well he laid
it out accurately in a way because more
and more Americans feel like government
works against not for them so you're
right they're dispirited and
unfortunately he and his one world party
are responsible for all of it
and no effort to reimagine his saggy old
self is going to change the facts that
under Biden Americans are falling behind
as China Roars ahead
together a growing distrust of
government and growing pessimism about
the direction of the country point to an
ugly future in the near term
and his obvious moves to Rebrand himself
again as some kind of Working Class Hero
they're going to fail as spectacularly
as his inflation reduction Act
the president's team is asking you
literally to suspend reality to sport
support Biden in 2024
remember the man who threw open the
southern border to cartels and criminals
now we're supposed to believe he cares
about record overdoses
welcome to Fantasy Island the Biden
Edition
fentanyl is killing more than 70 000
Americans a year
so let's launch a major surge to stop
fentanyl production in the sale and
trafficking with more drug detection
machines inspection cargo stop pills and
powder at the border
uh nice try but of course as we
mentioned last night on the angle most
of the drugs entering the United States
don't come through ports of Entry but
nice try
to imply that most fentanyl comes from
the Port of Entry is false it's a lie
most fentanyl sees that a Port of Entry
because they're fully staffed and every
car gets stopped but between the ports
and entry you said a minute ago 1.2
million gotaways do you think they
really care about the 70 000 Americans
dead from fentanyl really no they don't
because they did they secure the Border
then the man that Wall Street helped get
elected is trying to convince all of us
that you know come on forget Main Street
you know you know what he's their guy
for too many decades we imported
projects and exported jobs
now thanks to what you've all done we're
exporting American products and creating
American jobs we're going to make sure
the supply chain for America begins in
America the supply chain begins in
America
he's a regular Donald Trump
it sounds like trying to be made in
America now Biden should have slipped a
mega hat on right at that moment that
would have been perfect the fact is
under Biden of course the U.S trade gap
of china hit the second highest mark on
record
382.9 billion dollars
well China made Hunter rich and now
Biden is making China rich
heck of a job Joey
all is made in America lingo is just
poll tested his people know that that's
what Americans really do prefer American
jobs American made an American Focus
first
but when push comes to shove Biden's
always going to give in when Europe
demands that he make changes and it's
always against our interests
there's tweaks that we can make that can
fundamentally make it easier for
European countries to participate and or
be on their own never intended to
exclude folks who were cooperating with
us we're going to continue to create
manufacturing jobs in America but not at
the expense of Europe
yeah last night we were all supposed to
pretend that I guess we didn't hear that
remember this is Joe's Fantasy Island
I will make no apologies
that we're investing and to make America
stronger investing in American
innovation and industries will Define
the future this is my view of
blue-collar blueprint to rebuild America
and make a real difference in your life
but here at home inflation is coming
down food inflation is coming down
take-home pay has gone up period of
real people who actually go to the
grocery store know that Biden's faux
populist Act is falling apart
if insulting our intelligence we're a
sport Joe would be a gold medalist by
any measure American families are
struggling to afford even the basics
now why
because their wages aren't keeping up
with inflation
we're in a nosedive and Biden refuses to
pull up the controls instead he plays
make-believe in hopes that you're too
stupid to know he's crashing the plane
but hold on a minute at least he's
bringing America together
last night President Biden achieved what
Kevin McCarthy could never do which was
uniting the room trying to sort of give
everyone their flowers at the start of
this speech that really did set the tone
for Biden trying to show that he can
work with the other side again what
speech were these people watching he
catered to one of the most divisive and
anti-American groups out there BLM while
he pretended to care about law
enforcement
most of us in here
have never had to have the talk
the talk the brown and black parents
have had to have with their children I
know most cops and their families are
good decent honorable people the vast
majority but what happened to Tyree in
Memphis happens too often
we have to do better
we have to do better to indict all of
American law enforcement over the tragic
case of Tyree Nichols a black man who
died at the hands of black officers that
it doesn't make any sense
it's meant to inflame racial tensions
it's not meant to quell them
abhorrent and murderous people should be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law an investigation a prosecution will
we hope deliver Justice
but why didn't Biden with his Newfound
working-class empathy discuss the actual
reality of policing today
retention and recruitment down
massive shortages in major cities of law
enforcement it's making life there more
dangerous and criminals more Brazen not
to speak of the growing danger to the
officers who stick it out because they
love their jobs
officers like Peter jerving 37 year old
a 37 year old who was shot to death
early yesterday morning in Milwaukee
investigators say the 37 year old and
his police partner tried stopping
robbery suspect Terrell Thompson the
suspect fired at officer jerving officer
jerving fired back Thompson did not
survive the 37-year-old officer later
died at the hospital
heartbreaking
now this took place about what 90 minute
or so drive from where Biden spoke today
to his Union buddies in Wisconsin
but no mention from Biden
maybe because the man who killed officer
jerving had just been in court on Monday
for sentencing stemming from two hit and
run cases
the judge sentenced Thompson to four
months in the House of Corrections but
then he stayed or postponed that
sentence for a year of probation instead
also this week mckeesports police
officer Sean sloganski was shot and
killed Monday during a domestic
disturbance call for a man suffering a
mental health crisis
over the weekend an off-duty NYPD
officer 26 year old adid fayaz was shot
in the head during a Bosch robbery
he died just yesterday
and just a few hours ago in Philadelphia
an officer was shot during a vehicle
search
thankfully he survived but he's now in
critical condition
this is the world that Biden's
supporters Biden himself helped create
one where criminals have the run of the
streets and police are demonized one
where good hard-working people have to
raid their retirement accounts to pay
the bills
yet one where China is out maneuvering
us and our allies take advantage of us
one where American citizens aren't being
heard and illegal aliens are being
catered to
this is madness
and it's not a fantasy it's an American
Tragedy and it's time to turn the page
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else